[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue ça vous
regarde en direct je suis ravi de vous
retrouver au sommaire ce soir le conflit
se poursuit dans les raffineries la CGT
appelle à la grève dans tout le pays
pour élargir le mouvement à d'autres
secteurs mardi prochain la crise des
carburants se déplace sur le terrain
politique et les quelques jours à venir
seront déterminants c'est dans ce
contexte qu'on va s'interroger ce soir
sur les salaires la méthode forte
est-elle le seul moyen d'obtenir de
véritables hausses des entreprises pour
lutter contre la vie chère grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin ce soir à
analyser comme personne l'air du clash
dans laquelle nous sommes plongés depuis
l'existence des réseaux sociaux dans son
dernier livre il nous invite à l'art du
silence l'art du silence face au chaos
du monde c'est un essai qui a été initié
pendant le confinement sur le rôle de la
littérature comme refuge Christian
Salmon est avec nous ce soir enfin nous
retrouverons nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ce soir Stéphanie Despierre
nous racontera pourquoi les débats sur
le budget vir au pugilat Isabelle
Lasserre reviendra sur les déclarations
pour le moins surprenantes d'Emmanuel
Macron hier soir sur la dissuasion
nucléaire et puis Delphine Sabatier nous
fera entrer dans le monde rêvé de Mark
Zuckerberg voilà pour le menu ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
elle gronde la grogne sociale c'est le
scénario chrono de le gouvernement la
contagion du conflit dans les raffinés à
d'autres salariés ce soir les syndicats
de cheminots à la SNCF à la RATP annonce
rejoindre la grève du 18 octobre c'est
mardi prochain à l'appel de la CGT
malgré les nouvelles hausses de salaire
accordée ce matin par Total énergie on
va y revenir alors va-t-on vers un
mouvement de grève générale pour obtenir
des entreprises des hausses de salaire
bonsoir Marc Ferracci merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes membre de la commission
des affaires sociales députés des
Français établis en Suisse ancien
conseiller social de Jean Castex à
Matignon et vous venez d'être le
rapporteur de la réforme sur l'assurance
chômage qui a été votée il y a deux
jours bonsoir Philippe Brun et bienvenue
sur ce plateau député socialiste de
l'Eure membre de la nupes qui soutient
le mouvement de grève je ne dis pas de
bêtises même si je crois que les
socialistes ont quelques nuances sur ce
soutien vous nous direz si vous jugez ce
mouvement de local blocage légitime ou
pas bonsoir Benoît serres et bienvenue à
vous ravi de vous retrouver
vice-président de l'Association
nationale des DRH ce mouvement est-il le
prélude nécessaire à des augmentations
de salaire vous avez forcément un
certain nombre de capteurs dans les
entreprises vous nous direz ce que vous
ce que vous sentez enfin l'économiste à
l'OSCE François girolles van nous
rejoindre dans un instant le FC qui
vient de publier ces nouvelles
prévisions 2022-2023 sur le pouvoir
d'achat des Français alors on y va avec
vous pour commencer on ouvre le bal avec
le billet de Blacko pour faire le point
sur ce bras de fer si j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir messieurs si
j'ai bien compris ce soir alors si j'ai
bien compris Myriam la CGT et le
gouvernement disent exactement la même
chose il faut augmenter les salaires bon
le CGT on sait qu'elle veut les
augmentations mais ce matin sur RTL
Bruno Le Maire réclamait lui aussi des
augmentations au patron et pas seulement
pas trop de Total en écoute
toutes les entreprises qui le peuvent
doivent augmenter les salaires et total
je dis elle doit augmenter les salaires
il est évident que Total à la capacité
de verser des salaires de faire des
augmentations de salaire ils ont
commencé à le faire je pense que ça leur
pose absolument aucune difficulté
évidemment que total doit augmenter ses
salaires alors c'est fait en tout cas en
partie totale énergie à annoncé ce matin
une augmentation de 6% à ces salariés en
France au lieu des trois et demi déjà
négociés et une prime d'un mois de
salaire à tous les salariés de Total
dans le monde on va dire qu'en gros la
direction totale a repris en fait
l'accord qui a été signé chez sceau par
les syndicats majoritaires chez soi on
est d'accord pour si c'est ni pour son
angletation une prime 2 3000 euros sauf
que regardez dès aujourd'hui CGT et faux
on dit qu'ils étaient contre cette
proposition de totale on continue le
blocage aussi bien chez Total que chez
Esso il y a déjà il y a un accord signé
donc le gouvernement que fait-il bah il
tape du poing sur la table ça suffit et
donc c'est une réquisition qui a été
lancée la CGT voit il voit une atteinte
grève donc ils sont très en colère donc
Philippe Martinez et ce matin chez Apple
du Malherbe sur BFM
il était à deux doigts d'appeler à la
grève générale on était à deux doigts il
a pas dit à deux doigts
pourquoi vous dites pas le mot grève
générale
j'ai le droit d'utiliser le mot que je
le veux je pense
ça veut dire quoi grève générale ça veut
dire quoi il faut que dans toutes les
entreprises on discute de d'action et
généraliser les grèves généraliser les
grèves ça veut dire qu'il faut y aller
les grèves partout c'est pas une grève
générale en généralise la grève vous
comprenez quoi je vois je vois pas trop
la différence mais je vois que c'est pas
la même formule en fait le problème
c'est que les salaires augmentent moins
vite que l'inflation alors là vous
rejoignez carrément le point de vue en
tout cas les arguments des des grévistes
dans les raffineries parce que eux s'il
manque 10% pourquoi ils demandent ce
chiffre de 10% il considère que il y a 7
% qui correspondent à un alignement une
compensation de l'inflation qui est à
peu près de 6% et puis il y a 3 % qui
s'ajoutent d'augmentation qui serait un
peu pour participer au gros bénéfice que
Total Athènes cette année donc c'est le
problème que vous dénoncez c'est-à-dire
qu'il est plus général regardez les
courbes moi je suis daltonien donc je ne
peux pas vous dire qu'il a la rouge
qu'il est la verte mais ce qui est
très fort c'est la courbe des prix celle
qui grimpe moins fort c'est la cour des
salaires donc évidemment les fins de
mois deviennent difficiles alors que
faire on est en France dans ce cas là on
se retourne vers le gouvernement alors
le gouvernement qu'est-ce que vous
faites le Président c'est un peu de
plein de ça hier qu'on se tournait
toujours vers le gouvernement bon
Elisabeth borne et Premier ministre donc
elle fait valoir que malgré tout le SMIC
lui est aligné sur l'inflation on
l'écoute avec les housses automatique le
SMIC en un an a été revalorisé de 8%, je
vous rappelle que l'inflation est de 6%.
alors le problème c'est que tous les
salaires ne sont plus indexés sur la
façon mais c'est fini ça vous parlez
d'un temps que les moins de 40 ans ne
peuvent pas connaître vous êtes pas
connu non parce que ils ont été indexés
sur l'inflation les salaires sont 83
tournant de la rigueur après fini enfin
c'est pas tout à fait fini
dans les hauts de France il y a un petit
député qui résiste vous le connaissez
François Ruffin qui lui délai
législatives il réclamait justement
c'est indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation il n'est pas le seul
d'autres à gauche le souhaitent aussi
Fabien Roussel par exemple faisait cette
demande hier on l'écoute c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement d'inviter
toutes les branches professionnelles à
venir à Matignon et de dire maintenant
Mesdames et Messieurs les patrons il
faut une augmentation générale des
salaires le SMIC a augmenté pas assez à
notre goût mais il a augmenté nous vous
demandons que tous les salaires
au-dessus du SMIC augmente en fonction
de l'inflation sauf que ça le
gouvernement refuse de le faire mais
vous savez mais c'est le fameux charme
du du en même temps c'est-à-dire que le
gouvernement il est d'accord avec la CGT
mais en même temps il est d'accord avec
le Medef alors mais comment c'est
possible bah oui il est d'accord avec la
CGT pour augmenter les salaires mais il
est aussi d'accord avec le Medef pour ne
pas trop augmenter les salaires et tout
est un peu de questions de nuances parce
que quand on demande le patron Esco vous
pensez que ce serait une bonne idée de
caler les salaires sur l'inflation alors
là non franchement pas du tout Geoffroy
route Bézieux explique pourquoi et si il
parle du SMIC à plus 6%, c'est parce que
c'était au mois de juin ça a pas encore
été passé à plus 8 % l'écoute si tout le
monde augmente les salaires au niveau de
l'inflation on va nourrir l'inflation
très simple quand vous êtes restaurateur
70% de vos coûts c'est les salaires si
vous augmentez le SMIC augmenté enfin
augmenter pendant 6% cette année c'est à
dire augmenter le prix à la carte enfin
au menu de 6% et ça nourrit l'inflation
spirale inflationniste on va voir ça
d'ailleurs avec notre économiste c'est
que tout le monde est d'accord pour
augmenter les salaires maintenant il me
reste plus qu'à se mettre mon d'accord
sur le montant des augmentations on va
pas prendre énormément de temps je vous
laisse régler ce petit détail entre vous
on a une demi-heure merci beaucoup pour
votre pour votre billet Stéphane bon on
vous on va commencer sur le climat parce
que je disais que vous avez tous des
capteurs vous êtes des élus de la nation
j'imagine que vous êtes sur les marchés
le week-end qu'est-ce qui se passe à
votre avis marque Ferracci dans le pays
est-ce qu'on va vers un mouvement de
grève générale ça je ne saurais dire
j'ai entendu comme vous les propos du
numéro de la CGT non ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il y a il y a une situation
très compliquée pour beaucoup de pour
beaucoup de Français qui ont du mal à
trouver de l'essence pour emmener leurs
enfants à l'école qui en ont dans les
gestation mais ça n'est pas surprenant
ce n'est pas surprenant parce que c'est
une contrainte qui pèse vraiment sur le
quotidien c'est une contrainte qui
devient insupportable c'est une
contrainte sur laquelle un moment un
autre il faut qu'il y a un esprit de
responsabilité et je reprends ce qui
était dit à l'instant l'esprit de
responsabilité il touche évidemment
l'État et l'État comme vous l'avez vu à
engager un certain nombre d'actions et
notamment de réquisitions pour faire
bouger les acteurs
de la crise vous le reconnaissez ça vous
savez ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est que 10 jours
une grande partie de la crise est
alimentée et on le sait depuis le début
par le comportement des automobilistes
qui de manière très légitime vont faire
des réserves et son anxieux de pouvoir
remplir leurs réservoir pour la semaine
de travail et on ne boit bien que c'est
ça qui a catalysé la difficulté
d'apprendre et je répondrai à ma
question parce que l'État s'il avait
d'emblée quand il y avait 10% des
stations qui étaient en difficulté dit
qu'il y avait des problèmes de manière
massive on aurait amplifié encore ce
phénomène c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
ça un classique de la gestion de crise
faut pas dire ce qui se passe c'est ça
sinon vous organisez la ruée vers les
élèves il ne faut pas il faut essayer
d'éviter
vraiment on veut savoir ce que vous
pensez là-dessus parce que est-ce que
c'est pas aussi un peu total qui a
attendu une vingtaine de jours avant
d'augmenter les salaires je pense que
les négociations aura dû s'ouvrir plus
tôt ça j'en suis convaincu et on verra
on verra où est-ce qu'elles vont aboutir
je pense qu'elles auraient pu s'ouvrir
plus tôt alors évidemment comme le
disait votre votre collègue les
négociations n'ont pas lieu en continu
elles ont lieu normalement une fois par
an là total a fait l'effort les avancées
un petit peu mais c'était certainement
pas suffisant il fallait tenir compte du
contexte dans l'inflation tenir compte
de la revendication des organisations
syndicales pour se mettre autour de la
table beaucoup plus tôt ça de ce point
de vue je pense que effectivement
de la grève avec Total énergie les
syndicats on verra si la CGT se présente
ou pas Philippe brinvault soutenez vous
ce mouvement des des raffineries
bloquées ou pas question de souvenirs ou
de pas soutenir une situation sociale
moi je soutiens évidemment à la fois les
revendications salariales d'ailleurs
même Bruno Le Maire soutient le
revendications salariales maintenant
ça fait partie des méthodes de
discussion moi ce que je constate juste
c'est que le gouvernement a décidé pour
gérer cette crise de faire ce qu'il a
fait pour le covid au début
la méthode juste qu'on comprenne des
choses
vous soutenez le blocage dur des
raffineries qui bloquent le pays et qui
fait que les automobilistes aujourd'hui
quel qu'il soit sont dans une galère
épouvantable oui ou non sans une galère
épouvantable parce que Total a décidé de
ne pas dialoguer dans un premier temps
avec les parties prenantes dans son
entreprise et puis dans une galère
épouvantable parce que gouvernement a
décidé d'appliquer à cette crise qu'il
avait fait pour le covid d'abord de dire
qu'il y avait pas de problème ensuite on
nous a parlé de stock très stratégique
on les a pas vu c'est un peu comme les
stocks de masques et enfin le
gouvernement n'est pas parti des
négociations le gouvernement aujourd'hui
je crois doit se mettre au milieu des
négociations et qui est finalement la
leçon de l'histoire sociale de notre
pays quand on a des sujets aussi
importants
1936-1968 son négociation tripartite ou
l’état est présent pour vous c'est
contre-productif ça jette de l'huile sur
le feu c'est ça
doivent convoquer les syndicats et
évidemment les responsables d'entreprise
totale exon et avoir un accord commun on
est tous terminé la parole vous serez
dans la marche le 16 avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a un appel commun
effectivement à l'ensemble des Français
et mardi également derrière les
revendications céréales que tous les
français demandent et je rappelle quand
même qu'il y a 62 % des Français à son
âge qui est sorti qui soutiennent les
revendications salariales des raffineurs
en grève alors justement on va voir ce
sondage 40 % sont plutôt hostiles au
mouvement 42 soutiennent ce mouvement
difficile de dire qui gagne la bataille
de l'opinion avec un sondage pareil mais
c'est vrai qu'à 79% les Français
considèrent que le gouvernement n'est
pas à la hauteur dans cette crise alors
Benoît sert les remontées de terrain
vous vous êtes dans les entreprises
mardi finalement c'est ça la grosse date
parce que il y aura pas de train on
verra l'ampleur peu de métro comme il
n'y a pas d'essence ça va être très
compliqué aussi de prendre la voiture
donc ça risque d'être très compliqué
dans les grandes villes à Paris
notamment il y a plusieurs choses en
fait parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
l'enlisement ou de l'extension du
mouvement lui-même mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'on a déjà une contagion
dans le fonctionnement
quotidien des entreprises ça fait à peu
près huit jours que on a des gens qui
nous disent des commerciaux par exemple
disent moi je suis obligé de faire deux
heures pour trouver de l'essence donc du
coup je pourrais pas faire mes
rendez-vous la journée on commence à
avoir ça des gens qui peuvent pas venir
etc il y a un impact sur les économique
bien sûr comment on le voit comment les
gens qui vous dit moi je ne peux pas
venir parce que j'ai pu d'essence ou
alors je vais attendre deux heures déjà
quand même avoir faim donc on prend des
mesures partout on prend des mesures
partout mais même des gens bon les gens
qui arrivent en retard on va pas les
sanctionner évidemment pas de leur faute
donc voilà donc c'est et à la fois leur
location céréales on en parlera
certainement mais l'autre point si vous
bien comprendre qu'il faut sortir de ce
truc là parce que les entreprises
commencent à payer la facture tout
simplement le et tout le monde alors
évidemment on parle beaucoup des
soignants par les ambulances on parle de
tout ça mais pas que en fait partout
parce que j'en n'arrive plus à
travailler ou alors vous vous donnez un
jour télétravail supplémentaire parce
que j'en peux pas venir puis ça rajoute
quand même à l'ambiance générale qui est
quand même pas au beau fixe entre la
guerre et les sorties du covid qui
revient qui repart bon c'est vrai qu'on
a une ambiance on avait pas besoin de ça
après il y a la question effectivement
de l'inflation juste un point là-dessus
j'entends effectivement que depuis 24
heures le débat un peu changé de coup il
devient plus intéressant en quoi il a
changé aujourd'hui on entre qu'est-ce
qu'on entend d'ailleurs Stéphane
lakowski la très bien expliqué total
pour cet exemple là parce qu'on est au
corps d'actualité dit moi je veux courir
l'inflation si sous sept et 3% parce que
Total a fait des normes profits et donc
on est vraiment au cœur du sujet qui est
que il y a certes l'inflation ça c'est
des actions court terme dans beaucoup
d'entreprises les négociations ont
démarré beaucoup d'entreprises ont
avancé leur négociation exactement
peut-être que tout le temps aurait dû
faire c'est autre chose mais la vraie
question parce que sinon le problème
reviendra inflation ou pas c'est la
question du partage de la valeur
effectivement une société du travail
légitimement et d'ailleurs je sais que
ça a été avancé je crois pendant la
campagne présidentielle par Emmanuel
Macron faut travailler
c'est très important
[Musique]
on a un éminent le FCE moi quand je dis
les prévisions économiques les nuages
noirs s'annoncent demain donc tout le
monde a une réflexion un peu de prudence
pour protéger l'avenir justement merci
pour la transition bonsoir François
girolles bonsoir vous êtes donc
économiste d'abord avant de nous révéler
les prévisions qui sont d'ailleurs dans
la presse ce matin en Une de l'opinion
notamment quand les syndicats disent 6%
c'est pas suffisant là je reviens sur
total l'inflation en septembre c'est 5,6
en septembre selon l'Insee ils ont ils
ont raison les Féo s'est absorbé oui
alors faut quand même voir qu'il y a des
situations très différentes en fonction
des entreprises et que les entreprises
qui produisent de l'énergie par
construction sont plutôt gagnantes dans
dans les circonstances actuelles alors
que la France au global est plutôt dans
une situation beaucoup plus difficile et
perdante ou en France on doit se mettre
d'accord pour répartir un port d'achat
en baisse
ce qui est une situation toujours très
difficile à la fois pour les employés
les entreprises enfin voilà c'est c'est
quelque chose de très difficile parce
que par construction c'est plus facile
de répartir des gains que de répartir
des pertes par définition sur l'avenir
sur l'année qui vient de la fin
2022-2023 ça va continuer à baisser le
pouvoir d'achat de français on a pas
forcément des bonnes nouvelles on nous
prévisions nous disent que le poids
d'achat va baisser de 0,6% en 2023 et de
0,8 en 2024 donc enfin on anticipe que
la baisse de pouvoir d'achat va
continuer que l'inflation va continuer
en tout cas qu'on va pas avoir de reflux
des prix
alors ça dépend évidemment du scénario
qu'on prend évidemment il est très
difficile de faire des prévisions pour
les questions géopolitiques savoir si la
guerre en Ukraine va se terminer
rapidement ou pas savoir quelle va être
la réaction des pays producteurs de
pétrole l'OPE etc enfin ça dépend
d'énormément de choses qui sont pas des
économies qui à vrai dire mais quand
même ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on est dans
une situation difficile et que on est
dans une situation beaucoup d'autant
plus difficile qu'en réalité on a
l'impression que le gouvernement ne fait
rien pour le pouvoir d'achat mais qu'au
contraire quand on compare aux autres
pays d'inflation et relativement faible
en France en partie parce qu'on a le
bouclier tarifaire parce qu'on a eu la
prime à la pompe
exactement donc l'inflation en fait est
pas si élevé que ça en France si on
regarde les choses et donc le pire est à
venir en quelque sorte
euh juste sur la question de la spire à
l'inflationniste et puis ensuite on va
passer au négociations dans les dans les
entreprises c'est vrai que pourquoi
c'est si dangereux au fond d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation alors là il
fait pas forcément être en accord avec
avec mes collègues notamment économistes
qui ont travaillé sur ce sujet
exactement mais c'est vrai que je pense
qu'on a un discours sur la boucle
prélève qui est un petit peu trop
héritée des années 70 il faut expliquer
où on était où on était dans une
situation très différente ou comme vous
l'avez dit au début de cette émission
les salaires étaient indexés sur
l'inflation automatiquement et donc on
avait effectivement une boucle pré
salaire dans la mesure où devant un choc
de pouvoir d'achat comme celui qu'on a
actuellement c'est à dire à l'époque
c'était les chocs pétroliers en 73 et en
79 il y avait de la même façon la
facture énergétique de la France avait
augmenté et la façon dont le partage de
la valeur ajoutée c'était fait à ce
moment-là était automatiquement au
détriment des entreprises puisque les
salaires étaient indexés les salariés
les prix augmentaient les salaires
augmentaient de la même quantité
sauf que quand il y a pas de croissance
bah là ça s'emballe en fait mais à
l'époque non plus en fait il y avait pas
de croissance c'est juste qu'il y avait
des mécanismes automatiques d'indexation
qui faisait que sans négociation aucune
en fait il y avait la boucle préalable
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation un
peu différente ou ce phénomène se
déroule au niveau du SMIC uniquement
parce que le SMIC est indexé mais
l'ensemble des autres salaires est
d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu les salaires
augmentent seulement deux 3,5% comme la
montrer votre votre graphique en entrée
alors que l'inflation le problème il est
juste au-dessus du SMIC et pourquoi pas
y aller alors en fait dès que c'est vous
nous dites
oui enfin c'est clair alors oui oui non
mais alors après j'aimerais vous
répondiez mais vous êtes pas capable ou
pas sans aller jusque là en tout cas il
y a il y a un discours autour de la
boucle priscillaire qui amène peut-être
un tout petit peu trop prudent par
rapport au salaire en tout cas je pense
que c'est une discussion qu'on doit
avoir sur le partage moi je suis pas
voilà c'est c'est un débat qui est
politique
on regarde ce qui se passe dans les
entreprises Marc ferratti alors si on
parle des négociations au fond
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on peut obtenir
des augmentations de salaire il faut
qu'il y ait ce que les économistes
appellent des rentes dans une entreprise
qui sont issus de la productivité
l'innovation
syndicaliste il y a quelques années
parlait de grains moudre ce qu'il y a
des choses à se partager bon et puis il
faut que les salariés est un pouvoir de
négociation et le pouvoir de négociation
et dépend de plein de choses il dépend
de la présence d'un syndicat il dépend
de la situation du marché du travail
quand il y a beaucoup de chômage le
pouvoir de négociation a tendance à
diminuer c'est plus facile d'aller
négocier avec votre patron quand il y a
4 % de chômage et que vous pouvez aller
voir ailleurs
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
l'analyse qui est là pourquoi parce que
la France est un pays extrêmement
spécifique à deux titres
d'abord c'est un pays dans lequel 95%
des salariés sont couverts par un accord
de branche ce qui est quelque chose
d'assez spécifique quand vous comparez à
tous les pays de l'OCDE pourquoi parce
que sur les salaires dans la
l'activités
concrètement le ministre le ministère du
travail étant avec un mécanisme qui est
prévu par la loi l'ensemble des accords
de manière quasi systématique à toutes
les entreprises de la branche et pas
simplement les entreprises qui font
partie des organisations patronales qui
ont signé les accords et donc par
rapport à d'autres pays et conventions
collectives ont un impact très important
ça veut dire très concrètement que quand
le SMIC augmente et bien en général les
minimas augmentent alors ils peuvent
augmenter avec retard c'est ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de minima de
branches qui sont en dessous du SMIC
parce que le SMIC a augmenté plusieurs
fois dans l'année et qu'il faut
rattraper avec les négociations cet
élément là mais concrètement
l'augmentation du SMIC tire les minima
de branches à la hausse et le deuxième
spécificité dont on n'a pas parlé c'est
que le SMIC il est pas simplement indexé
sur les prix en France il est indexé sur
les prix et sur de salaire ça veut dire
très concrètement que le SMIC fait
augmenter les minimas et les minima de
manière rétroactive ont un effet du fait
cette indexation du SMIC sur les
salaires sur l'augmentation du SMIC et
cette circularité elle est non mais elle
est présente un effet
vertueux pour les salariés évidemment et
c'est tout à fait légitime mais la
difficulté de tout ça et je rejoins ce
que disait Benoît sert c'est que il y a
des entreprises qui sont capables
d'assumer ces hausses un petit peu
mécaniques des grosses entreprises
pas toujours mais celles qui ont des
possibilités et puis il y a celles qui
ne peuvent pas et d'où les effets emploi
dont il faut se préoccuper c'est très
important
mérite qui nous montre qu'en fait les
entreprises et ben elles sont pas
attendu ce bras de fer avec total pour
et bien commencer à négocier certaines
ont même l'ont même déjà fait tour
d'horizon avec les Américains
certains grands groupes ont préféré
prendre les devants pour éviter un
conflit social Air France dont les
contes viennent à peine de repasser dans
le verre à augmenter les salaires de 5%
pour tous ces salariés chez Bouygues les
augmentations seront comprises entre 4
et demi et 6 % la SNCF elle communique
sur une hausse de près de 6% en moyenne
depuis le début de l'année assez inédit
puisque on retrouve des niveaux qu'on
n'avait pas connu depuis 40 ans le
rapport de force est quand même beaucoup
plus favorable aux salariés qu'aux
employeurs depuis que le chômage a
baissé et la spé salariale est assez
importante pour leur attractivité donc
elles sont obligées quelque part au delà
du maintien du pouvoir d'achat des
basses salaires d'augmenter leurs
enveloppes salariales pour attirer ou
fidéliser
mais beaucoup de grands groupes
préfèrent accorder des primes
ponctuelles 1000 à 1500 euros chez LVMH
1000 euros chez ArcelorMittal jusqu'à
1400 euros chez stelantis
au-delà des grands groupes certaines PME
ont aussi choisi d'augmenter les
salaires comme cette enseigne de fruits
et légumes elle vient d'accorder une
hausse générale de 4% avec une prime
pour certains employés quoi notre rôle
premier c'est quand même de protéger nos
collaborateurs qui sont quand même les
forces vives de l'entreprise pour être
très clair
et tout simplement en fait essayer de
faire en sorte nos collaborateurs soient
bien et reste le plus longtemps possible
chez nous mais même les augmentations
les plus généreuses ne devraient pas
compenser totalement la perte de pouvoir
d'achat liée à l'inflation l'Insee tape
sur une hausse des prix de 6,4% à la fin
de l'année
Philippe Brun on se rend compte qu'il y
a un rapport de force qui s'inverse un
peu dans l'entreprise à la faveur des
salariés avec la baisse du chômage
est-ce que vous diriez que on peut leur
faire confiance aux entreprises dans le
cadre de ces négociation pour arriver à
des hausses de salaire effectivement
qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer
en fait c'est un rattrapage sur les 20
dernières années dans les pays de l'OCDE
les salaires ont stagné et à cause de ça
la rémunération du capital les
dividendes eux ont augmenté explosé et
là on a finalement un rééquilibrage du
partage de la valeur de l'entreprise que
disait interlocuteur juste avant et donc
là on est en train de faire ce
rééquilibrage il se fait de manière
je veux dire dans la négociation dans le
contrat entre les partenaires sociaux la
négociation qui est en train d'être
faite vous tapez sur Google grève os des
salaires il y a plein d'entreprises en
France qui sont dans lesquelles les
salariés sont en grève pour avoir une
dose d'elle par exemple Lactalis on en
parle absolument pas mais il y a des
grèves en ce moment pour avoir des
hausses de salaire de la manière forte
il y a des grèves et la grève n'est pas
le seul moyen il y a des négociations
ensuite moi je crois voilà que
législateur nous sommes législateur doit
faire son travail et que l'État doit
faire son travail et je crois que dans
un moment aussi critique pour les
Français nous devons avoir résoudre à la
fois par la loi et par la place de
l'État dans les négociations les
Français mais ça va une chose c'est que
c'est pas l'état qui qui augmente les
salaires quelle loi
on a augmenté les salaires et on avait
fait des accords écouter là le pays est
totalement bloqué je crois que l'État on
est bloqué comme en 60 minutes en 68 il
y avait pas non plus d'essence en 1968
pompes il y avait pas de pompe à essence
les gens ne pouvaient pas les travailler
mais sont surdites on n'est pas loin de
cela
convoque aujourd'hui les syndicats et
les patrons pour se mettre d'accord sur
une trajectoire de hausse des salaires
c'est ce qui se passe dans on va tuer
l'économie si on ne le fait pas parce
que en jouant on le voit bien que son
regard ne fonctionne pas plusieurs
choses la première il y a effectivement
aux entreprises sont en grève il y en a
aussi beaucoup qui ne sont pas tout
simplement parce que les négociations
ont démarré voir ce sont achevés vous
avez quelques exemples
où il y a pas de problème de main
d'oeuvre parce que quand il y a un
problème de main d'oeuvre là on voit
bien que les augmentations sont rendus
tous les jours tout le monde est
énormément d'entreprises ou le sujet
était réglé le deuxième problème il y a
une chose qui c'est vrai c'est que ça
fait 20 ans que vous avez pas un
dirigeant en France qui a dirigé des
boîtes avec une inflation à 6 quoi et
donc aujourd'hui tout le monde est en
train de regarder quel équilibre j'ai
entre la hausse de mes coût de
production qui est phénoménale mais aux
coups de salaire qui est légitime et
donc on trouvait le bon équilibre donc
ça c'est la deuxième chose je pense à en
revanche que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
là on va petit à petit on va corriger
par l'état d'être mise autour de la
table moi je connais
je suis désolé monsieur mais je vois pas
convoquer les patrons alors le Medef ou
une entreprise du romédef vous êtes
gentil mais moi je fais ce que je veux
dans mon entreprise vous avez des
entreprises qui sont dans des situations
elles sont incapables de le faire il
faut l'accepter c'est comme ça c'est pas
bien pour les salariés c'est encore vous
savez que l'entreprise préférée
attention de le faire donc je suis pas
certain que mettre l'état entre les deux
soit les bonnes solutions parce que je
suis pas sûr que ça crée ça créera en
revanche l'État et les parlementaires
ils ont un rôle très important
d'accélérer parce que sinon le problème
on l'aura dont je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure je on avait annoncé des réformes
structurel sur l'intéressement la
participation sur l'actionnaire salarié
sur le parc tout ça sinon sinon on
risque de retrouver le même schéma dans
6 mois juste après
assez rassurant vous savez jusqu'à
maintenant on est aussi une fois par an
parce que les inflations étaient faibles
beaucoup d'entreprises intègrent dans
leurs accords de négociation aujourd'hui
le fait que tout le monde se revoit en
juin parce qu'on sait pas où est-ce
qu'on voilà et donc
conjoncturellement aujourd'hui mais
structure allemand et ça c'est le rôle
des parlementaires et de l'état
peut-être juste pour pour peut-être une
proposition qui pourrait être un peu
plus consensuelle ce serait parce que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement
incite les entreprises à donner des
primes et non pas des hausses de salaire
donc peut-être que ceci devrait être
rediscuté dans la mesure où aujourd'hui
on discute plus de hausse de salaire
alors au départ le gouvernement se
disait
l'inflation va retomber et donc il faut
surtout pas perdre en compétitivité vous
faire très attention aux hausse de
salaire et donc on va inciter les
entreprises non pas à plupart des
augmentations de salaires mais à donner
des primes est-ce que dans le contexte
actuel on va pouvoir d'achat
je suis pas en train de dire que c'était
évident il y a 6 mois de savoir que
l'inflation est durée mais dans la
mesure où elle dure est-ce qu'on peut
pas rééquilibrer un petit peu les choses
entre les primes et les hausses de sacs
il y a deux difficultés à gérer la
première pour l'évoquez c'est
l'incertitude bon l'incertitude fait que
le profit d'une année ne peut peut ne
pas se reproduire les années suivantes
et comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
les augmentations de salaire elles elles
sont acquises et c'est bien normal la
deuxième difficulté c'est je rebondisse
sur ce que disait monsieur Brun c'est
l'hétérogénéité des entreprises si
l'État se met autour de la table comme
il l'a fait en 1968 avec les accords de
Grenelle c'est pour décider
d'augmentation généraliser des salaires
qui vont embarquer dans une petite
différence
pour différencier en fonction des
capacités réelles de chaque entreprise
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
augmentations indifféren côté de salaire
accessoirement 68 on était une époque on
faisait 4 à 5% de gain de productivité
par an à l'époque il y avait 2% de
chômage la situation n'est pas tout à
fait la même et je pense que le sujet
n'est pas tout à fait transposable si on
fait le gouvernement
c'est la réponse à la question de
l'incertitude quand on a de la
difficulté à percevoir ce qu'est
l'avenir et quand on a de la difficulté
et bien à embarquer tout le monde dans
des augmentations indifférenciées de
salaire que ce soit à travers le SMIC ou
à travers les minima branches parce qu'à
l'intérieur d'une branche
professionnelle les entreprises sont
très hétérogènes il faut bien se le dire
il y a des petites il y a des grosses et
un moment un autre il faut éviter ce
syndrome du filet dérivant qui quand on
augmente les salaires de manière trop
indifférencier détruit des emplois pour
terminer ce débat Philippe bring
j'imagine que vous vous poussez la taxe
sur les super profits on parlait de la
du partage de la valeur là le
législateur il a des outils des outils
fiscaux parce que si cette taxe d'une
certaine façon
contribution alors je sais pas comment
utiliser en tout cas c'est un débat ce
qui a été mis sur la table par Bruno Le
Maire ça vous suffit ou pas une
contribution la contribution qui est
proposée elle est minimaliste touche
uniquement le secteur de la raffinerie
des cockeries on n'est pas du tout sur
la taxe c'est super profit qu'on avait
imaginé non je pense qu'il faut aussi
poser la question de la question des
salaires la question des causes de
l'inflation parce qu'on a pas
effectivement une inflation dans les
années 70 on est l'inflation qui a une
source elle est essentiellement
énergétique et donc moi je crois qu'il
faut peut-être réfléchir à
temporairement cesser d'appliquer le
cadre européen aujourd'hui du marché de
l'énergie et qui nous coûte d'ailleurs
extrêmement cher de l'Union non se
mettre d'accord au niveau européen pour
que on revienne sur ce marché ridicule
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on produit notre
électricité en France on a commercialisé
10 fois 20 fois plus cher mais seul en
France a vraiment être pénalisé et les
autres ont envie d'y rester
manifestement très cher aux finances
publiques le bouclier tarifaire ça va
quasiment être 50 milliards d'euros moi
je crois que si on mettait on mettait en
question ce marché européen de l'énergie
et bien on règlerait le problème de
l'inflation c'est d'avoir besoin
d'augmenter des salaires de 10%
petite question petit tour de table ça
m'intéresse de savoir comment
on fait pour pousser un pays vers cette
idée du partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises c'est l'intéressement la
participation principalement ça c'est la
loi c'est possible aujourd'hui vous avez
à peu près 50 % des séries qui ont accès
à ça c'est vrai que moi je connais bien
le système il est assez compliqué pour
récupérer l'argent sur le gouvernement a
pris une mesure qui était maintenant
vous pouvez retirer jusqu'à 10000 euros
je pense qu'on aurait pu aller plus loin
parce que ça c'est de l'argent donc à
partir aux gens donc ça aurait résolu
une partie du problème immédiator je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'incidations
supplémentaires pour engager les PME à
le faire de manière à ce
qu'effectivement on partage la valeur
créée parce que le risque et c'est un
peu ce qui est évoqué c'est que à
vouloir une hypothèse journal de salaire
on va partager la valeur qui n'a pas été
créée ça crée des problèmes je pense que
ça c'est un vrai sujet puis c'est une
vraie aspiration des salariés vraiment
des employeurs restaient aussi donc
clairement clairement vous avez des
entreprises assez connues qui qui depuis
longtemps ont des participations
intéressantes je pense qu'il faut
vraiment dispositif d'association
fiscale non pas pour les grandes mais
pour le petit pour le faire on va suivre
ça de très près normalement
deuxième mandat d'Emmanuel Macron merci
beaucoup on va s'arrêter là merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat on va à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin on
le connaît pour ses essais l'air du
clash le storytelling qui pointait dès
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux les
dangers d'une société de plus en plus
transgressive basculant dans La Poste
vérité aujourd'hui il signe l'art du
silence aux éditions des liens qui
libèrent un livre népendant le
confinement sur la littérature comme
refuge quand le monde devient trop
chaotique on accueille Christian Salmon
juste après l'invitation signée ce soir
par Marco pommier
si on vous invite Christian Salmon ce
n'est pas pour jouer au roi du silence
référence à votre dernier livre l'art du
silence tout un programme
Christian Salmon vous êtes écrivain
chercheur engagé vous l'êtes aussi en
1993 vous fondez le Parlement
international des écrivains pour les
auteurs persécutés dans le monde de vous
nous retenons aussi vos analyses sur le
storytelling l'art de raconter les
histoires mais quand trop de récit tu le
récit le risque c'est d'entrer dans
l'air du clash dans votre nouveau livre
vous explorez l'oeuvre de romancier qui
ont d'après vous une certaine expérience
du silence de Franz Kafka assalman
Rushdie en passant par MYLAN kundeira
une expérience du silence dans un monde
en hyper crise dans l'actualité ce soir
la tempête sur les marchés financiers
mystérieux virus de la même famille que
le sera a déjà contaminé 45 personnes
les livres d'histoire retiendront cette
date le 24 février 2022 le début d'une
guerre comme l'Europe n'en a pas connu
depuis des décennies des crises qui se
super propose s'enchaînent ajoutées à
cela le toy bohu des réseaux sociaux et
des chaînes d'information en continu
alors Christian Salmon face à la
dictature de la parole face au tumulte
du monde quel sens donnez-vous au
silence ce livre explore les différentes
facettes du silence littéraire au 20e
siècle il témoigne de ses œuvres n'ont
pas arraché au silence mais creusés dans
la matière du silence dont la matière et
le silence bon il faut l'avouer on a
parfois un peu de mal à vous suivre ce
que nous comprenons c'est que vous
pointez du doigt les ambianceurs ces
raconteurs d'histoires qui meuble le
vide détourne notre attention mais la
solution est alors de se retirer loin
très loin de faire pénitence au fin fond
d'un monastère ce soir notre question
est simple en apparence dites-nous oui
dites-nous à quoi ressemble concrètement
l'art du silence
[Musique]
bonsoir Christian castelmon et merci
merci beaucoup d'être là alors répondez
qu'est-ce que c'est concrètement cet art
du silence auquel vous consacrez votre
dernier livre c'est si vous voulez le la
réponse que la littérature offre au cas
où du monde c'est à dire que et plus que
jamais tout au long du 20e siècle mais
plus que jamais depuis le début de ce
21e siècle où on a une sorte de
succession de crise
politique terrorisme climatique
sanitaire etc et ce que j'avais appelé
dans un livre précédent le storytelling
c'est-à-dire la multiplication des
récits d'adaptation à ces crises mais
qui ne fonctionne pas et qui d'une
certaine manière alimentante le
discrédit de la parole publique donc le
la question de que pose ce livre c'est
qu'est-ce que la littérature peut
apporter
comme réponse à ces crises euh on a
toutes sortes de de de de symptômes et
en cette rentrée c'est particulièrement
sensible je suis frappé de voir combien
les climatologues les anthropologues les
ethnologues parlent de crise du récit
c'est-à-dire de Anastasia Martin le
disait récemment dans le monde nous
avons pas métabolisé la crise climatique
viens moi
d'entrée de jeu dans l'introduction on a
un immense défi narratif et vous dites
que ce défi il existe depuis le 11
septembre en fait depuis qu'on a connu
cette attentat sur les tours jumelles
terrorisme catastrophes écologique krach
boursier pandémie crise géopolitique on
a toujours ce même défi narratif oui
chaque chacune des crises c'est vrai
depuis le début du 20e siècle avec la
Première Guerre mondiale a été le
premier choc et le premier défi narratif
Walter Benyamine disait nous ne
rencontrons plus des gens capables de
raconter une histoire que nous vivons
alors nous après la deuxième guerre
mondiale aussi
nous nous vivons nous subissons une
suite de choc entre lesquelles il n'y a
pas de possibilités d'articuler de
raconter etc mais c'est particulièrement
sensible depuis le 11 septembre parce
que le 11 septembre a été au fond le
premier événement du 21e siècle qui a
plongé les gens dans une sorte de
stupéfaction de stupeur de voir ces deux
tours s'effondrer ça a créé une sorte de
et c'est très frappant ça multiplié les
questions sans réponse et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a un pont où il y a un
écho parce que vous avez commencé ce
livre vous le racontez dans
l'introduction pendant l'expérience
inouïe qu'on a tous vécu du confinement
et c'est dans cette expérience où au
fond tout est mis en cause on a vu le
complotisme sur le virus on a vu à quel
point la raison était était bousculée
que vous venez à la littérature
d'ailleurs à la faveur aussi d'une forme
d'injonction à cette époque là on était
tous chez soi il fallait lire des livres
c'est ce qui avait dit le président de
la République
une littérature comme refuge avant de
nous décrire votre Panthéon parce que ce
sont des écrivains d'ailleurs vivant ou
non il y a cette phrase en exergue c'est
une adresse à votre éditeur vous mettez
dans le livre cette extrait du lettre ce
serait un livre non pas sûr Kafka mais
avec Kafka dans le moteur comme un tigre
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire écoutez
c'était mon éditeur me proposer pendant
le confinement d'écrire un livre sur
Kafka donc c'est la réponse que j'ai que
je lui ai proposé c'est à dire que je
pense que Kafka est emblématique en fait
de la réponse littéraire aux crises
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
justement vous savez il a écrit une
série de nouvelles sur des portraits
d'artistes et il y a notamment une de
ces une de ces artistes qui est
Joséphine la cantatrice des souris et
Joséphine dans la nouvelle d'un coup
refuse de chanter et donc elle rentre
dans une sorte de silence c'est une
métaphore si vous voulez de pour moi le
silence des écrivains ou le silence de
la littérature c'est un peu une ligne
d'ombre c'est la ligne d'ombre qu'il
faut traverser pour sortir des langages
codifiés que vous connaissez très bien
vous Myriam puisque vous interviewez des
politiques et vous êtes là
vous traversez une sorte de c'est un
petit peu comme le carré blanc de
Malévitch dans la peinture ou le ou le
ou le ou la pose musicale dans la
musique c'est à dire le le quelqu'un
comme Proust qui est extrêmement prolixe
qui a écrit une œuvre considérable je
raconte comment cette oeuvre est tissée
dans le silence
qu'on a besoin d'acousticien ce mot est
très important explique le nom oui alors
ça ça c'est une réponse vous savez à la
fin de storytelling je dis qu'il faut
une contre narration et souvent me
demander mais c'est quoi cette contre
narration j'écris ce livre pour essayer
d'expliquer ce qui pour moi était cette
contre narration c'est-à-dire que je
pense que le récit la narration tout ce
qu'on fait on célèbre aujourd'hui c'est
pas quelque chose de cons actuelle c'est
quelque chose de qui provoque des
dissensus et je dis dans le livre
j'explique bon il y a au fond il y a les
acousticiens les véritables écrivains et
il y a les ambiances sœurs c'est à dire
ceux qui pendant les crises jouent un
peu le divertissement raconte des
histoires miroirs dans lesquels on peut
se reconnaître et cetera les
acousticiens ont une oreille et Kafka en
est l'exemple parfait
il sentent un peu comme des animaux sans
que les catastrophes à venir les
secousses sismiques les grands écrivains
sentent et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
d'une actualité brûlante en ce moment
par exemple moi je l'ai je ne fais pas
de si vous voulez de l'histoire
littéraire au sens
universitaire pas du tout justement
delilo ou encore Proust il y en a
d'autres dans le livre il y a un
chapitre par par romancier d'abord c'est
votre Panthéon mais expliquez-nous
pourquoi eux et qu'est-ce qu'il est
relié
d'abord ce qui les relie c'est une
expérience commune du silence j'ai été
frappé en composant le livre qui est au
fond une chambre déco quand on passe
d'un auteur à l'autre on voit que c'est
il se répondent il se parle tout en
étant
leur vie étant étalée dans le tout le
20e siècle donc il y a cette expérience
commune vigilante mais aussi ils ont
ils nous offrent une fantastique
capacité de penser sur ce que nous
vivons c'est-à-dire que par exemple je
parle de Joseph Conrad Joseph Conrad
j'en parle pour parler de l'attentat du
11 septembre Kafka je le ressuscule dans
le confinement puisque dans le château
de Kafka on trouve une expérience de la
distanciation qu'on a tous vécu pendant
le confinement enfin tous ces auteurs
nous parlent d'aujourd'hui
volodin par exemple nous parle de la
crise de Tchernobyl à travers son roman
etc donc c'est fantastique de voir
comment des auteurs dans la vie c'était
allé sur tout le 20e siècle jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous parle en fait de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et apporte un
éclairage je trouve une capacité de
problématisation de narration
que les discours politiques économiques
médiatique ne nous apporte plus aussi
c'est important pour vous dans cette
dans cette liste le rapport forcément à
l'actualité oui le rapport avait c'était
absolument terrible parce que je venais
terminer le livre
quand donc il y avait ce chapitre déjà
écrit quand Salman a été
agressé mais vous savez j'ai créé une
institution il y a des années qui était
le Parlement des écrivains dont Salman
rushdier était le président ce qu'on
appelle c'est dit dans la presse en
France aux États-Unis oui c'est que
lorsqu'il a été agressé cet été c'était
il était en train de commencer un débat
avec quelqu'un que je connais bien qui
avait créé la ville refuge de Pittsburgh
et le débat était consacré à l'accueil
des écrivains menacés c'était
précisément ce qu'on avait fait avec le
Parlement écrivain donc c'était si vous
voulez cet agression était un cauchemar
qu'on avait porté pendant des années
qui se réalisait de manière dramatique
donc ça montre à quel point la
littérature c'est pas un divertissement
c'est un enjeu réel c'est les corps et
on n'a pas parlé de du prix Nobel Danie
non mais
la polémique qui a été soulevée autour
de son prix Nobel est exemplaire parce
qu'au fond ce n'est pas seulement les
opinions politiques puisque c'est une
écrivaine engagée à gauche tout le monde
le sait ce n'est pas ces opinions
politiques étaient dénoncées par ce
qu'ils ont attaqué c'est le monde
qu'elle a porté qu'elle a rendu visible
qu'elle a rendu audible c'est-à-dire
cette ce monde un peu exclu de de la
visibilité le monde des pauvres gens le
monde et qui existe enfin les politiques
l'appellent ça la France d'en bas elle a
donné à ce monde là
son langage ces signes et c'est ça à mon
avis qui est refoulé donc le rapport je
dis au début du livre aussi la fiction
menace le monde et le monde s'efforce de
la conjurer c'est assez ça la
littérature est apporte un formidable
défi
au monde et je crois que c'est très
important pour la vie démocratique de
défendre cette littérature vous nous
ramener à la littérature pour au fond
sortir d'une forme de Tite de tétanie
aussi face à un monde qui est de plus en
plus effrayant certes bruyant chaotique
violent mais aussi très très effrayant
je voudrais vous ramener à la langue
politique parce que on est à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez regardé les miss
cycle la manière et on va en parler
d'ailleurs avec nos chroniqueurs dans un
instant c'est parfois le pugilat
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les
politiques avec le niveau de langage je
vais vous citer et j'ai essayé de
trouver dans dans chaque bord politique
arrêté d'emmerder les non fascinés ça
c'était Emmanuel Macron manger récemment
Daniel obono Darmanin on ne va pas
légaliser cette merde à propos du
cannabis ce matin même à France Inter
Laurent Berger qui est rarement
transgressif sans portait en disant
bordel et puis bon Éric Zemmour c'est
même pas la peine c'est le niveau d'un
condescence de la culture du clash
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben écoutez je
l'avais j'avais tenté de l'expliquer
dans mon livre l'air du clash
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
plusieurs facteurs qui se rencontrent
c'est-à-dire il y a les réseaux sociaux
il y a les algorithmes les gafams et il
y a au fond le le l'espace public du
débat démocratique c'est complètement
transformé je vois toujours derrière
vous cette émission pour moi magnifique
parce que c'est l'Agora des Grecs et
l'Agora des Grecs c'est c'est une
architecture de la démocratie aussi un
peu tout le monde doit s'entendre doit
s'écouter un ordre de parole etc toutes
ces règles de la vie démocratique du
débat démocratique sont bousculés parce
qu'aujourd'hui le débat a lieu dans les
réseaux sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
et la loi des réseaux sociaux c'est la
loi de la transgression maximale
c'est-à-dire que pour être redouté pour
être il faut créer une sorte de
transgression permanente d'aller
toujours plus loin dans la brutalité
dans la vulgarité pour être repéré et la
langue du politique est contaminée voilà
alors justement pour sortir de la
twittérisation du débat public et bien
l'art du silence c'est aux éditions des
liens qui libèrent merci beaucoup
Christian Salmon parce que les romans
s'ils nous n'enseignent pas grand chose
finalement il abrite la vie c'est l'une
de vos phrases dans le livre merci
beaucoup merci à vous on va accueillir à
présent nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris ce soir Stéphanie Despierres va
nous dire pourquoi les débats sur le
budget vire au pugilat Isabelle Lasserre
va revenir sur les déclarations pour le
moins surprenant du chef de l'État hier
soir sur la dissuasion nucléaire et
Delphine Sabatier nous fera entrer dans
le monde rêvé de la marque Zuckerberg
nous affranchis au féminin pluriel ce
soir les voici bonsoir à vous trois
on commence par Stéphanie Stéphanie vous
suivez forcément ces débats budgétaires
à l'Assemblée le temps pour la majorité
ça le temps pour la majorité notamment à
cause du modèle cette nuit on appelle ça
en langage moderne une carte postale les
troupes de François Bayrou on envoie de
temps en temps pour se rappeler au bon
souvenir du gouvernement cette nuit donc
surprise le modem réussit à faire passer
un amendement contre la vie de Bercy
c'est clair et net 227 voix pour 88
contre il ne s'agit pas de taxer les
super profits mais de taxer plus les
dividendes versées par les entreprises
qui font des super profits et non ceci
n'est pas une fronde explique le modem
une question de fraude c'est une
question de
justice sociale j'aurais préféré qu'on
emmène la majorité présidentielle avec
nous et je comprends absolument pas le
fait qu'il n'est pas compris ce qu'on
voulait c'est-à-dire le vrai sujet c'est
quand même le partage de la valeur et
quand on fait ça oui on partage la
valeur c'est il y a quelque chose
d'indécent à entendre que des
actionnaires puissent effectivement
faire gagner des super dividendes alors
qu'on demande des efforts à tout le
monde là on n'empêche pas l'entreprise
de fonctionner au contraire on l'aide à
garder l'argent à l'intérieur pour
investir et partager avec les salariés
alors le MoDem a bénéficié du soutien du
rassemblement national et de toute la
gauche avec les marcheurs les seuls qui
ne sont pas obligés de faire grève pour
être augmenté c'est les actionnaires
les seuls qui n'ont pas besoin de
quémander pour se gaver ce sont les
profiteurs de guerre et donc on va voter
l'amendement de notre collègue parce
qu'il prend le pognon là où il faut le
prendre pour le donner là où on a besoin
et surtout Myriam 19 députés Renaissance
sont eux aussi voté cette proposition
alors à défaut de s'attaquer au super
profit l'aile gauche des macronistes a
voulu quand même envoyer un signal
politique
j'ai surtout voté pour une mesure qui
vise à trouver le bon équilibre attendu
par les français concernant tous ces
profits exceptionnels qui sont réalisés
sur les questions pétrolières c'est 5
points au dessus de la de la fiscalité
habituelle c'est
raisonnable je crois acceptable de la
part du monde économique
mais ne vous inquiétez pas le groupe
Renaissance va bien selon sa numéro 1
qui peut exister et qui s'est exprimée
sur un amendement voilà encore une fois
il y a pas un pistolet sur la tente des
parlementaires c'est pas comme ça que
les choses se passent et s'organisent
dans un groupe politique voilà c'est pas
évident pour la majorité on le sent bien
ce matin rebelote la majorité
Renaissance à nouveau au battue dans le
cycle et cette fois c'est le modèle qui
vote avec toute l'opposition pour le
retour de l'exit tax alors c'est un
symbole fort car c'est un marqueur du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
qu'il avait supprimé en 2019 pour éviter
la fuite des jeunes entrepreneurs vers
l'étranger et puis plus tard dans la
matinée pour éviter cette fois d'être à
nouveau battu et bien les macronistes
changent de stratégie et décide au tout
dernier moment de soutenir le
rétablissement de la demi part fiscale
des veuves la chef des députés
Renaissance souligne donc leur capacité
d'écoute l'heure n'est pas encore au
49,3
cette semaine c'est le temps du débat il
doit être approfondi allé jusqu'au bout
des sujets la semaine prochaine en tout
état de cause il faudra un budget pour
la France alors Bruno Lemaire
tiendra-t-il son agenda l'après-midi a
été un peu moins difficile pour le
gouvernement dans l'hémicycle mais là ça
commence à se tendre et les troupes
s'impatientes il y a une très grosse
pression des députés renaissance pour
écourter au plus vite la discussion
beaucoup ne voit pas l'intérêt de passer
du temps à débattre de ce texte qui de
toute façon finira adopter en 49,3 et
avec la version du gouvernement merci
beaucoup Stéphanie Despierre a priori
pas cette semaine à dit Bruno Le Maire
qui est prêt à tenir la tranchée un peu
plus longtemps toute façon vous vivrez
tout ça en direct évidemment si cette
arme constitutionnelle est dégainée
Isabelle vous vouliez revenir sur
l'émission de d'Emmanuel Macron la
grande interview d'hier soir sur France
2 drôle de manière pour un chef de
l'État de répondre à une question sur la
réponse qu'aurait la France en cas de
frappe nucléaire tactique de la Russie
sur l'Ukraine oui Emmanuel Macron a dit
des choses qu'un président français
devrait jamais dire donc le président
d'une puissance dotée de l'arme
nucléaire écoutez-le
est-ce qu'une frappe tactique de la
Russie serait considéré par la France
comme une attaque nucléaire
la France a une doctrine nucléaire je le
disais et notre doctrine repose sur ce
qu'on appelle les intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation et ils sont définis de
manière très claire et donc ce n'est pas
du tout ça qui serait en cause il y
avait
par exemple une attaque balistique
nucléaire en Ukraine ou dans la région
par contre ça n'appellerait pas une
réponse nucléaire
conventionnelle d'évidence et ça n'est
pas notre doctrine aujourd'hui je le dis
nous avons un cadre pour ce qui nous
concerne et oui Myriam alors là Emmanuel
Macron sous-entend que si jamais
Vladimir Poutine lançait une arme
nucléaire tactique contre l'Ukraine ou
bien contre la région c'est-à-dire
contre les pays européens pour reprendre
l'avantage dans la guerre il ne
répondrait pas par du nucléaire alors
sur le fond il est évident que le
président français formule une évidence
les pays occidentaux ont envisagé
plusieurs scénarios notamment la
destruction totale de la flotte russe et
des installations militaires mais
personne absolument personne ne veut
prendre le risque d'une guerre nucléaire
généralisée le problème c'est que dans
cette affaire il ne faut pas le dire
puisque la dissuasion nucléaire repose
justement sur l'ambiguïté sur le flou
alors le président français aurait dû
faire comme François Mitterrand il
aurait dû dire je ne m'exprime pas sur
le sujet mais attention Vladimir Poutine
les conséquences d'un tel acte seront
tellement dévastatrices que tu
il le perd aussi à l'est ou ses alliés
ne manqueront pas de se dire que
finalement que décidément on ne peut pas
compter sur la France en cas d'attaque
nucléaire à suivre est-ce qu'il a fait
exprès ou pas c'est toute la question
Delphine nous reste un petit peu moins
de 4 minutes vous nous parlez ce soir du
monde rêvé de Mark Zuckerberg le patron
de Facebook meta c'est son nouveau nom
et vous nous dites alors là cette vie
révéla moi non merci et je suis pas la
seule et pourtant moi j'adore
l'innovation et on parle quand même de
d'un futur qui est en train d'être
construit par l'entreprise à la tête de
service qui ont séduit des milliards de
personnes dans le monde alors donc c'est
intéressant quand même de regarder
pourquoi aujourd'hui ça ça marche pas ça
prend pas déjà peut-être donnez moi
votre avis sur les images que vous allez
voir défiler est-ce que c'est zavattar
de personnes en 3D tel qu'elles sont
représentées aujourd'hui de manière
assez simpliste dans ce métabère de Mark
Zuckerberg est-ce que ça vous trouvez ça
époustouflant non logement bon si je
vous apprends que la grande promesse de
cette semaine c'est que bientôt ces
avatars vont pouvoir marcher sur leurs
jambes parce que pour l'instant ils sont
statuts les avatars n'ont pas de jambes
articulaires c'est un peu trop compliqué
à calculer est-ce que vous vous dites
waouh incroyable non plus
on est d'accord donc franchement c'est
vrai que c'est un concentré de
technologie c'est serait compliqué de
l'expliquer ici mais d'un point de vue
esthétique comme ça au premier regard
déjà on n'y est pas ça ne nous fait pas
rêver en plus pour accéder à ce monde
virtuel ça casque très compliqué il faut
avoir tout un attirail qui coûte en plus
très cher la l'annonce de Mark
Zuckerberg c'est l'arrivée d'un nouveau
casque de réalité virtuelle il a pas du
tout été conçu pour nous il faut le
savoir parce que vous voyez le prix qui
s'affiche 1500 dollars il est conçu donc
pour des entreprises qui ont peut-être
une chance un jour de de l'amortir bon
alors quelle est la promesse de ce
nouveau monde virtuel alors c'est la
question que les parce que quand même on
a mark Zuckerberg qui voit grand le sait
si on connaît tous bah c'est parce que
quand même il est à la tête de cette
révolution de la communication entre
nous les humains c'est quand même
incontestable avec facebook Messenger
Instagram WhatsApp on a totalement
réinventé la manière dont on communique
ensemble et donc ce méta vert pourraient
être une nouvelle la prochaine
révolution des interactions sociales
donc c'est pas rien quand même alors
vous allez me dire c'est-à-dire
précisément
c'est précisément on n'en sait rien du
tout ce projet il est encore très flou
et même pour être sincère je pourrais
dire qu'aujourd'hui on voit vraiment pas
l'utilité de ce métal vert proposer par
méta en revanche on voit déjà bien les
risques exemple alors exemple regardons
déjà ce qui se fait avec les réseaux
sociaux on voit la viralité incroyable
de la désinformation la marchandisation
des données personnelles la haine en
ligne la surréaction permanente enfin
bon cette confiance qui existait un peu
nous et les plateformes elle a quand
même été brisée en tout cas pour une
partie des utilisateurs et je ne crois
pas que simplement des avatars en 3D un
peu souriants suffiront à la restaurer
donc si Mark Zuckerberg veut vraiment
convaincre que son état vert c'est
l'avenir il va falloir qu'ils donnent
envie aussi à la jeune génération
d'utilisateurs mais aussi de
développeurs de bâtir ce nouveau monde
avec lui or en particulier en Europe
aujourd'hui les technologies on y
cherche plutôt un nouveau souffle des
réponses aux grands enjeux de l'humanité
les enjeux énergétiques les enjeux
sociétaux sociaux
bah là pour l'instant on voit pas le
sens on voit pas le sens et moi mon
hypothèse c'est que aujourd'hui les Gafa
et ben ils ont quand même pris un sacré
coup de vieux parce que leurs
aspirations bennes rencontrent plus les
nôtres merci merci beaucoup je suis pas
loin de partager votre votre constat
vous c'était l'oeil sur le numérique
signé Delphine Sabatier merci à vous
trois les affranchis à demain très belle
soirée documentaire avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien
[Musique]